Wolverine Logan James Howlett whatever
you call him the facts remain the same
Wolverine is the best there is at what
he does and what he does usually isn't
very nice but just how big a jerk is he
in the comics here's a look at the most
terrible things Wolverine has ever done
he drowned his own son Wolverine has a
whole lot of descendants which is just
par for the course for a near immortal
animal guy with poor impulse control
worst of them all though is a son Dakin
who inherited his father's mutant
abilities and bloodlust only without
that pesky conscience to go along for
the ride a trained assassin Dakin
actually defeated his dad and stuck him
in a vat of water to drown since even
with a healing factor Wolverine still
needs to wool verb read however after a
timely rescue by Deadpool Wolverine got
free track down Dakin and in a bit of
karmic retribution drowned him in a
puddle
dad dad more kids more murder the
Mongols were a team of super villains
sent to fight Wolverine by a secret
group of bad guys who called themselves
as a red right hand since apparently
every good team name was already taken
after being trapped in hell don't ask
Wolverine gets free and goes on one of
his patented revenge benders
killing all the mongrels in the process
it's only after they're all dead that
the red right hand reveals the mongrels
were children of Wolverine and it was
all a big ploy to make him feel really
bad about himself way to think small
guys he tortured an American soldier
Frank Simpson was an abused mentally
disturbed child who killed his own
mother think somehow actually got worse
for Frank though when Wolverine murdered
his father and then forced him to join a
government program that manufactures
superhumans after emerging from the
program a total wreck Frank was sent to
Vietnam where sadistic Wolverine then
tortured and brainwashed him into
becoming the mindless murder machine
known as nuke so why exactly is Logan
considered a good guy again oh right
because Hugh Jackman sings Who am I I'm
Aubrey
nein he set up colossus for a beat-down
Wolverines fellow x-men Colossus and
Kitty Pryde have long had an on-again
off-again romance back when Colossus
first M kitty though Wolverine was none
too happy about how his comrade handled
the situation so he decided to teach
Colossus a lesson by getting him drunk
and then letting juggernaut deliver a
massive beat down on the overmatched
hero yep
while Nightcrawler wants to intervene
and help their friend Wolverine refuses
insisting that Colossus has been coming
for being such a heartless CAD he's not
necessarily wrong and compared to
repeatedly murdering his own children
it's pretty low on the list of bad
things Wolverine is done but you know
think twice before enlisting Logan as
your wingman an infinite number of jerks
in the comics there's an infinite number
of alternate universes meaning there's
an infinite number of jerks named
Wolverine running around doing horrible
things don't believe it well say hello
to Wolverine the vampire Lord who after
being turned into a vampire by Dracula
infects the rest of the x-men and then
goes on a murderous spree killing the
rest of the superheroes like you do then
there's the age of apocalypse Logan who
calls himself Weapon Omega his plan was
to help alien beings called the
Celestials completely wipe out all
humanity because reason naturally in the
course of the story he also murdered his
own daughter because that is apparently
just how Wolverine rolls then there's
the infamous original old man Logan
storyline which was one of the
inspirations for the movie Logan in the
comic book version
Logan swears off violence after is
tricked by an illusionist named Mysterio
into murdering all of the x-men this is
what happens when you never learn anger
control dude ultimate creep as bad as
all those other versions of Wolverine
are the worst has to be the ultimate
universe Wolverine who is consistently
written as an amoral villain who just
happens to be working for the x-men it's
impossible to list all of his misdeeds
but among the worst are the time he
straight-up murder too scared mutant kid
because he was worried about bad
publicity for the mutants after the boy
lost control of his powers then there's
the time he tried to kill Cyclops
because he wanted to make out with Jean
Grey but probably the worst is when Jean
Grey mine swamped Logan with the teenage
Peter Parker to teach Logan a lesson
only to have Wolverine use it as an
excuse for some very inappropriate
interactions with underage high school
girls basic
Wolverine is just messed up thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll
whew
[Music]